balances ton école d'art c'est le nom de
la page facebook sur laquelle les
premiers témoignages sont apparus ce
week end des étudiants de l'isba pointe
les agissements de g et de l2 membres de
l'équipe pédagogique qui aurait lors de
soirées alcoolisées abusé de leur
autorité pour harceler sexuellement et
pratiqué des attouchements sur des
élèves masculins par téléphone une de
ses victimes nous raconte d'anciens et
actuels étudiants de lys bas ce sont
donc montés en association et ont déposé
deux plaintes l'une pour harcèlement
sexuel l'autre pour agression sexuelle à
l'encontre des dénommés l egée mais ce
n'est que le début
depuis qu'on a publié les posts sur
facebook on a reçu plusieurs messages de
la part de d'étudiants qui sont dans
d'autres écoles d'art notamment l'école
de bourges l'école de l'union et l'école
de aix en provence qui sont dans des
démarches un peu similaire au nôtre et
du coup l'idée ça va probablement être
de décès décidé de créer un truc un peu
intérêts coll voilà dans un communiqué
les enseignants témoignent de leur
soutien aux élèves et demandent la tenue
d'un conseil d'administration
exceptionnel
de son côté la direction de l'institut
ne se défausse pas mais fait le dos rond
et je fais confiance en la justice de
mon pays à l'instruire à les plaindre et
puis à l'erreur ce qu'il en retourne je
peux absolument pas sur des faits aussi
graves dire autre chose
l'école des beaux-arts de besançon est
un établissement public donc sous la
tutelle de l'état et de la mairie anne
vignot se veut ferme jamais je n'aurais
peur de quelque chose qui se dit il faut
que les langues se délient il faut que
la situation de d'autorité que certains
s'autorisent elles soient abandonnées
donc je n'ai peur de rien j'ai jamais
peur de la vérité balances ton école
d'art va-t-il être le mythe ou des
étudiants aux filières artistiques
c'est en tout cas pour l'instant parole
contre parole